[Music]
it's almost noon yet turning huh Oh
welcome to the Jenna and Julian pot cat
wait if you're like gonna whisper than
her no I was just afraid cuz I came
under the mic super high came in so hot
came in hot
remember that game we used to play Oh
game that we used to play this airplane
game it was like an airplane simulator
on our iPhone it looks correction you
used to like I used to light and it was
like super like realistic and so far
it's been really shitty gravity we first
crashed and it gave me mass amounts of
anxiety well cuz like you have to do
everything perfect to land cause you
just fly from island island and every
time I was coming in landing on the
island I would go over to Jenny be like
Jen I'm coming in hot coming in hot and
then I was just completely wrecked and
played on the runway to out what you're
sorry
um but that was a really fun game yeah I
couldn't play that at all because I
could never believe it okay it's the
epitome of stress turn it up a little
what sorry he's okay but yeah I would I
would just [ __ ] crash and burn every
time until I figured out like you could
pull back in the throttle even then
ballet why much is crashing more like
even when you pull back on the throttle
you just go burn and you like lift back
off sort of and then you fall down and a
little slightest mistake will make you
crash I don't know it was called yeah I
don't know but I was like Julian what
are you doing so here's this like awful
like it's just like the airplane zone
feel like a half an hour well cuz okay
what are you doing and he's like it's
just so relaxed okay this game is like
why Julian sick by the way really flying
this plane and I'm like why is that
relaxing that looks awful and then like
I was like I'll give it a try and like
I didn't realize that you could not go a
million [ __ ] miles an hour I'm like
Julie this games is terrifying all I'm
doing is just crashing at it like
90-degree angle to the ground I think
it's this awful this is amazing we'll
stop going so fast I didn't realize that
that was a thing you could do well cuz
the thing about this game is like it
really didn't cut out any of the
nonsense like if you're flying three
miles or four miles or 15 miles it would
take that much time as a would real life
so you're just like mmm it doesn't speed
anything up so [ __ ] boring you don't
even have to do anything when he wants
your coat you just Coast I found solace
in it it was awful
well I deleted it cuz it took up a good
[ __ ] gig I don't have [ __ ] time
that takes up so much space julian has a
sick it has a sickie he's allergic to
Oregon well maybe we came back from
Morgan and I got pretty sick
he was like wheezing yeah I was wheezing
today so I had to get like a breathing
treatment the nebulizer uh which made me
really shaky mmm I've had it before the
drugs in there do you have sports
induced asthma who knows you know I did
too when I was a kid I had asthma I
would carry around that inhaler that the
doctors today and then just you know in
high school I just stopped having it
yeah so super weird to have it again
just like right at woods you got lerczak
to organ that's your deal I think so
yeah maybe I came I came we came into
San Francisco and I was like boom sick
yeah yeah it hit me at once really weird
but I'm like on the I'm the upswing of
it so should be all good by tomorrow
got some steroids to take for my
wheezing anyway oh my god steroids good
stairs thanks good steroids um we we
went to Oregon to visit Jenna's brother
and her baby niece and that was really
nice they're so nice it was nice I've
had my knees her bottle and read her
story she's like nine months old and it
was like one of the most special things
I think I've ever done in my
her life because she looks just like
Devon she looks just like Devon and it's
just so adorable you know she can't
really talk yet she can try and stand up
but she can't walk she can just sort of
crawl around but she knows like she does
this little hand motion that they're
trying to teach her for like water or
like drink or milk they're trying to
teach her like little baby sign language
which i guess is the real thing I
thought that was made up for a while but
it's totally not totally real and uh
they were saying she just does this
thing where she was like if for those
who they're listening and can't see what
I'm doing right now she basically just
takes her hand and like has it in like a
semi fist but then just stretches her
fingers out like 800 [ __ ] times in a
row that's basically like gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme and they like what
does that mean and my brother and his
wife are both just like well it's
supposed to mean milk but it just means
like anything give it to me yeah but the
way that you can communicate with her is
incredible dude I mean like all she can
do is cry or laugh or like you know
stare around I really it did blow me
away the way that yeah I mean ah this
might sound stupid but I didn't even
know she could laugh yet and yeah you
making her laugh it was like holy I know
I was taking my sleeve and giving her
elephant kisses oh my god that was the
most adorable thing oh that was the most
adorable thing on the planet to me and
babies me and we get along we're like at
the same level of maturity
I'm jealous dude that's really cool in
general well you you really have a way
with her it was super cute yeah I mean
like once you're holding there's no
babies in my family no one's ever had a
baby I don't have any like real cousins
that were younger than me and I'm still
waiting mom for my baby brother sister
that I've been asking for since forever
I don't care that you're in your 60s all
right make it happen get legs God but um
she's really the first baby that we've
had in our family and so it's very
magical and I held her and fed her
bottle and read her story and like she
can pick which book she wants to be read
watch she has favorites and she's only
nine months old cute and she's like she
has favorite things and she's just we
were building her blocks and she would
just wait till it gets really high and
then just she was just not good and she
wants you to set up her blocks for her
let put them on top of each other just
so she can knock it down with her hands
magical it's it's just amazing how much
of the rest of the world doesn't matter
when you have like a little baby that
just wants to hang out with you yeah
that's true oh oh my heart hurts in love
but anyways yeah Julian got sick yep we
got Zach we're back from Oregon and
Christmas and we wanted to do one final
podcast of 2014 the last podcast of this
year yeah we've been going a good while
we're proud of us let's talk about our
new year's resolution by the way okay
can i sorry track for a sec yeah
so I think it's sort of a joke amongst
everyone ever that you're you know New
Year's resolution goes away after a
little bit yeah yeah yeah I do however
know a person that without fail always
keeps going yes yes Jill yes yes I do
Ann this is gonna be a little bit of a
tangent right now but Jill is my friend
from college and we played softball
together we live together she is the
person that everyone loves like everyone
loves I've never met a person that
didn't like Jill and it's not because
she tries to have people like her she's
just a genuine good-hearted person she
loves fun she's non-judgmental like I
don't think I've ever really heard her
say anything bad about anyone else he
would but if you wanted to sit there and
vent at her like she'd be like yeah man
she loved death but even if she ever
said something that was like mildly bad
about anyone else would always be in
such a hysterical way that you can't
even you don't even know she's serious
she is so funny she's deeply religious
did you know that I didn't know there
were many times in spring training that
she would you know before a doubleheader
in our 10th game of six days
wake up earlier to go to church but you
know you'd think that that might cause
some conflict between Jill and some
people no oh no she just loves and
respects
that's incredible religion ever that's
pretty crazy and I think it's really
important as a person to have peers that
you admire and idolize you know I think
for almost everyone that I know that has
ever met her and has ever known her is
that person and Jill is the only person
I've ever known that has kept their New
Year's resolutions along with what she
gives up for Lent is so hardcore like we
saw her in November yeah and my do Jill
only ever drinks like either wine or
hard alcohol and the place we were at I
think only served wine or beers or
something yeah I think I asked her
something like ah do I'm gonna get you
like a vodka sprite or something even
though I didn't know they didn't have it
she was like no no I gave up soda for
New Year's
it's my new year's resolution like it's
[ __ ] November she's like yeah I know
I almost made it I'm like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about you didn't hear
that no I did I did I remember as I said
the hazard of any soda but it might
adjust if it was something like Red Bull
I know something something like serious
tangible yeah but it was November it was
our trip to New York it was like it just
threw me for such a loop because I
hadn't seen Jill in a long time and I
forgot that she's literally the only
person that I know yeah that could just
ever throw that casually into a
conversation at the end of the year like
oh no I can't there's a my new year's
resolution you're like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about people stop talking
about their resolutions by library
February where the Jim dies down yeah
but she one year she gave up McDonald's
which I kid I could never possibly
describe to you how much Jill loves
McDonald's just plain hamburgers and
Eminem Nick flurries I'm gonna McFlurry
she knows what she's talking about that
[ __ ] Oh
gave it up for Lent one year and the
second she like New Year's what Lent was
over oh okay we like how to make a
beeline to McDonald's
died yeah that's so cool though I love
that it's something really cool about
someone who does that it's Jill in a
nutshell yeah except way more fun and
awesome
Jill is amazing I mean when we when your
friends came over like what that year
ago for your for your surprise party and
I mean she was cracking me up the entire
time yeah that's what she is
she just crushes it she's so hilarious
um I mean I don't think I don't keep my
resolutions so much I don't really make
serious ones yeah I don't really make
serious ones either I think last year
the year before my resolution was to
make sure that my dogs did something fun
for dogs every day which I you know
after a few months chalked up to just
like oh you guys can go run in the yard
yeah well like I'll throw your toy for
you yeah you know at first I started out
as like you know make sure they get a
really nice walk they're going to go to
the dog park or go for a hike or
something but it really you know a lot
of days we're gone or like not here like
how out of town yeah life happens so I
think that's what happens for most
people with their resolutions is looking
at it's a wonderful idea yeah in theory
but in practice is kind of a myth it's
hard like it's hard because yeah and you
know a lot of a lot of resolutions that
people make and that are easy to make
like only get fit or I want to stay fit
or whatever they're very broad so in
January that goal well yeah I mean well
even if you just want to be like I want
to get in the best shape of my life like
in January the best shape in your life
looks different than it does in August
like in August you're saying well you
know I'm in pretty good shape I'm pretty
much in the best shape of my life
this'll do you know I mean like you
start to like well cause that's not I
got you okay when you make a broad goal
you're just immediately setting yourself
up for failure because it's not a
tangible goal if you said by the end of
2015
yeah I want to lose good god I want to
win yes ten pounds that's a tangible
goal but a lot of people don't know how
to effectively set goals that they can
rewrite no you're right you know you're
right it's common yeah for sure but
something tangible like I want to give
up soda and then keeping that until no
is ridiculous that's [ __ ] wild do you
have any that you've been thinking about
um well I had something that I wanted to
do but most people I think would find it
silly I don't think so it's here I just
I want a dry bar dry brush my body every
day with that dry brush the wrong one
yeah all right well you're tired one
night when you didn't driver-side they
nobody yell at you and me you got a dry
brush [ __ ] get that dresser I'll just
Rob at you while you're sleeping okay
but only feels so good well if you do
for my legs up in a circular body motion
circular motion okay if you're asleep
you don't know what circular motion is
scratching you for those of you that
don't know dry brushing is really balm
and I did a lot of reading on it before
I got a brush and I loved it but it is
hard to do something every single day
like honestly I get like tired sometimes
at night like it used to be hard for me
sometimes to just do simple things yeah
I mean like [ __ ] there's just so many
so many things that you have to keep up
with where you're like alright I'm
[ __ ] exhausted sometimes I go to bed
at 7 or 8 in the [ __ ] morning yeah
and I'm like alright what can I afford
to do right now take my makeup off take
my contacts out I'm going to bed
yeah I might even stand there and brush
my hair [ __ ] a hundred times no am I
gonna stand there and floss every single
one of my teeth [ __ ] no like I got in
my bed man
you know if sleep is important yeah
absolutely it is
but when sometimes it is daunting I
think being a girl just knowing the
amount of maintenance that you [ __ ]
have I'm like [ __ ] man yep [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
but I do I want it I want to make every
single day looking dry Bush every
weekday okay every weekday okay I think
that's a better goal I like green
because Sunday's we all know I'm not
getting out of my [ __ ] pajamas
unless I have to uh yeah the weekends
you might need off of dry brushing just
out of sheer time concern so good for
you though in front of you that don't
know what I'm talking about it's like
you basically take a natural bristle
brush and you like either do long
strokes or circular upward motions on
your skin dry with
nothing yeah it's really exfoliating and
it drains your lymph nodes and it has
like a lot of health benefits and it
feels [ __ ] good and your skin looks
bomb yeah yeah I like it
can I borrow you can I do yours on
weekend oh you you're not going to be
using the Mohican get your own dry rot
all right I'm gonna min the market for a
dry brush you won't get your eyebrows um
yes weekdays I will dry brush my teeth
like that
Oh matarese and sundays are bonuses okay
Saturdays what if you miss um one day
Sunday's I'm like bye well if you go
like what if you go five days in a row
right and then it's Sunday you're like
Tuesday's really busy coming up I want
to dry brush on Sunday so I can take to
that no see you can't do that you can't
barter with yourself that's how you fail
yeah you know you're right that's true
that's true that's exactly right
it was a test and you passed you cannot
make deals with yourself because we all
know how that ends up really I'm only
gonna eat three bucks is the macaroni
and cheese this week tonight
okay this hour now you're a teen you're
absolutely right thank you for calling
me on that because that's so true yeah
true
that's if you're if you're debating
making a deal with yourself that's how
you know you're going down the path of
like you're not gonna stick to the
beginning or fail and you're absolutely
right yeah no bartering yep
just shut up and do it just right rush
your [ __ ] body it literally takes you
know 30 seconds yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna try and I anticipate
that I will not be able to do it yeah
but it's a it's a lovely goal yeah and I
don't think there's any harm to me not
doing it this is not a life-threatening
thing for me to not dry brush my body
every day well if it makes you feel good
and it makes your skin feel better I
mean it's it's a great it's a great goal
I love that thanks Julian I don't think
it's weird at all Thank You Julian for
not judging me can i watch you dry brush
Barbies sorry what's your news
resolution hmm I don't know I've been
thinking about this for a while and I'm
not sure if this is kind of crazy but
wait can I correct myself I think I said
lymph nodes I think
to say lymphatic system yeah anyways
lymph nodes alright she chooses this the
one hour in the entire week that we
podcast not easy house exploring naughty
little dog alright excuse her well it's
it's to do with Olympic weightlifting
and their specific numbers I give them
to us so let me just give it should I
just say my numbers now so it gives you
a little context okay so there's
clean-and-jerk in there snatch my PR my
personal record in clean-and-jerk is 125
kilos which is how many pounds which is
275 pounds that's the most of clean and
jerk I've cleaned hundred forty kilos
which is three hundred and eight pounds
I just can't charge now yeah jerking is
putting it on your head and snatch I've
snatched about 90 kilos which is roughly
200 pounds it's like 198 pounds so with
the way I've been progressing in this
new gym and this new team and stuff I'm
nowhere near it right now but I think
that I could clean in jerk a hundred and
fifty kilos by the end of the year which
is three hundred and thirty pounds which
is roughly 30 more pounds than I can
jerk right now you can do it so as much
as I think like a you know as a tangible
goal the tangible goal and like I've
thought about this number for a while
because 150 is like it's a pretty
paramount number it's like okay 150 it's
pretty right there and I feel like I've
cleaned close to like you know a little
over you know 1/4 I've clean like 135 I
think multiple times like for a double
or something which is good and I think
as I like get more strength and I get my
technique now it'll be it'll become
pretty good the jerk is what is going to
be the hardest part of that you can do
it thank you that's what that's what my
new year's resolution for I think that
you can absolutely jerk that much weight
as long as you learn to rest your
shoulder sometimes I think that's true
Julian sometimes get so excited about
lifting the heavy things that I think
that you underestimate the value of rest
you're right
I come home and I'm just like I'm all
over the place with it you're right know
that
maybe taking like a day off of not doing
overhead stuff like you're pretty good
about that for the most part yeah but
what I see happening is sometimes you do
too much overhead stuff and then your
shoulders sore then you have to take a
week off yeah and then I'm back to
square one yeah barely being far I think
in order to reach your goal that you
need to be patient with yourself and
understand that it's a marathon no
you're right you're absolutely right
thank you
mm-hmm life coach [ __ ] right there
that's for real though shut up no I'm
serious like you get caught up in it too
like especially in the atmosphere where
there's a team and you all see people
working together you're like oh I'm
bigger than that kinda like yeah but you
really just gotta keep your mind that's
right yeah keep patience and keeping
those four goals in the forefront of
your brain patience is probably one of
the most difficult things in life to
master absolutely absolutely it is very
hard it's very difficult yeah if ever
you forget how difficult patience is
just try and feed your dog a treat while
they sit or stay it runs just in it's on
and they're just like that you see like
Kermit or peach just start to like
shiver because they're so excited just
for a little treat that's how difficult
patients is yeah you know that should be
my new year's resolution to get think
about think about how excited Julian
you'd have to be in order to shiver
everywhere well their minds are so
focused on one thing it's like there's
no external anything that's that trees
it's taking every ounce of their being
to be patient yeah you're right cuz dogs
are wonderful because they live in the
moment which I think everyone should
live their life more like we're like
more in the moment more everything yep
absolutely it's very very difficult to
be we should be we should live more like
dogs for sure yeah that's why it's so
honest and loving and amazing to be with
a dog because you know they're not
anywhere but with you that will just
stare you they love you they're simple
yeah all they want is just really fun to
think about that comparison like try to
live more like dogs it really can't be
applied though it sounds a little
far-fetched but it can be applied no
live in the moment they do that's it's
really as simple as that moments the
moment yeah they appreciate what's there
you know they live it on the contrary
you can live on like dogs and be patient
with your shoulders and not like your
[ __ ] not like your [ __ ] that's why
that's how you should not live like dogs
don't eat things that will require
surgery later yes don't eat things that
were all cryosurgery later don't eat
like weird socks and stuff or condoms
off the street oh god I've heard of a
lot of people's dogs having it like
condoms and some very little bellies
okay can't horrible eat that little baby
little [ __ ] up you'd feel if you like
look haha Jules sorry too far Rome
happy birthday Rome too far everywhere
they roamed use mob are everywhere roman
heavy bread oh my god do you have any
other resolutions that you even think no
that's it I just wanna I make one you
know yes that's how I feel you want cuz
if you dilute it then it's just like
well yeah you start going into your like
mind bank of everything that you've like
that also being you fail miserably
Jacqueline ever well well and then also
like if you drop one you're like it's
okay I got this work which is like why
did you even have that first one in the
first place you take one and then you
try and stick to it for as long as you
can and it's just a judgment between you
and yourself so if you fail no one's
really gonna be mad at you but everyone
kind of knows that we all fail a little
bit yeah absolutely unless you're Jill
and you're a saint
in which case you keep it until November
she's alright until New Year's to [ __ ]
drink a soda whatever the [ __ ] she gave
up well yeah she's crazy she'll just
crack one open at 12:01 and be like it's
nothing guys I did it again like I do
every year that's a seriously cool
quality though this person for sure
that's why I jails Jill fresher um also
happening this week is a fight that
we've been waiting for yeah we talked
about Jon Jones versus Daniel Cormier a
long time ago on a podcast we dedicate
like a whole podcast to it because of
all the lead-up to it
but then the fight got so mad at me
because I was like okay
it was super hypothetical hey you should
watch all week that podcast in the
description of this podcast by yourself
mad at me um well it's just okay so
first of all we were talking about that
fight because of the lead-up to it was
so intense like there were exchanging
words and then even there was like a
fight at the press conference and it was
just wild but then they got who Jones
know Daniel Cormier got injured I think
and the fight got pushed back all the
way into New Year's so it's happening on
Saturday which is a good four four
months after we first asked about but we
are no no less excited I'm dying to see
it it's going to be a great fight so do
you alright so if you were to just like
describe the five it's Sunday right now
and this person is just like oh hey I
missed the fight why don't you tell me
what happened oh you know I'm not good
at this I hate this
Julianne's always like alright what do
you got and I'm like what do you mean
what you mean who he's like no hot like
who is gonna go down there and win how's
it gonna go down Julian no I'm not good
at that [ __ ] alright like I have a
general knowledge of MMA in the UFC I
don't have quite the bank of knowledge
to draw from to create hypothetical
fight no no fair enough fair enough
um I do think that John Jones is going
to win okay um I don't know what round I
don't know how I'm sorry to disappoint
you but I think it's worth noting I
don't think I've ever talked about this
in a podcast or video or anything my
method of picking who wins yeah we
should talk about that
um all right yeah talk about that so I
don't know how this started but it's
freakishly accurate like it blows my
mind it's still it's beyond I don't even
know how it happened I don't know how it
started I don't know how it works but
all I know is that it's beyond
probability at this point yes it can't
just be chance no there's something
further so the way that I decide who
wins regardless unless it's like a super
super like if GSP is fighting I'm like I
can't pick yeah like the ESPYs I want
him to win yeah I don't
care I just want yeah but every other
fight ever
you know Julian's always got his pick
and he's like oh so until it's gonna
crush this person and I'm like all right
whatever I'm not watching any the
beginning I don't want to know what
their last fight was like even though I
[ __ ] watch it like you just don't
want to see anything good and then they
play the little card that has their
heights they're rich they're with tale
of the tape yeah and it goes well
they're their picture it has to be that
one it has well there's two there's an
initial one before they show the
walkouts
and then right when they're in the ring
yeah it's not that it's not that well
not that one say there's the [ __ ]
one hey that was a good impression of it
Thanks uh it's right when they're in the
ring
Bruce is getting his [ __ ] ready right
and he goes and it shows their height
weight record
height weight record reach reach and now
leg reaching an age Oh like I don't know
that's it that's gonna be uh that's
gonna be added in 2015 I believe they're
adding leg reach final is he [ __ ]
should ranks matter Dave alright yes so
they play that music over there pictures
with all those stats and I just look
into their eyes I'm not joking I hasn't
told me you know I look into their eyes
regardless of who they are and I just
figure out who has a dub in there I like
who has the win it's alright for those
guys is that she said who has the what
the win the dub a dub in there I yeah
because they're looking at the camera
they're like they're like this most
likely or they're like this but they're
looking at the camera so general looks
into their eyes and just looks past
their eye and reads into who has a dub
in their eye and she picks that person
and they [ __ ] win yeah nine percent
of the time I've had a couple of nights
where I've had perfect perfect nights
and all okay so and Julian will have all
these upsets like oh my what the [ __ ] oh
yeah because I like know someone
I'll blow this guy's gonna I mean he's
got this fight in the bag and general be
like no the other guys get the dog like
okay dub whatever and then they win and
I'm like okay that's [ __ ] weird but
okay um hold on the the last card that
we watched Pettis the Pettis and the oh
and the Lawler card that was the first
time and I think maybe like a year and a
half where I had tweeted out all five of
my main card picks and got them all
right yeah yet I'm pretty sure you've
done that probably like 10 times last no
because I don't have that talent I can't
just say who I thinks gonna win because
if I were to pick they'd all be [ __ ]
backwards and wrong I need to do it in
real time as they show me the ha I don't
know until that very moment who's gonna
win and sometimes I'm wrong number we've
watched the fight though where I was
like I don't know like this happened a
couple times I'm like I don't know they
both have a [ __ ] dub in there I the
most notable of which I think I can't
remember what [ __ ] happened I think
it happened during the Silva Weidman
fight when Silva got his [ __ ] like
like snapped in half but there was
another one where it was like a complete
controversy like everything was super
[ __ ] up like wasn't one and then
Saleem oxygen wasn't when yo Romero got
got off the stool too late against Tim
Kennedy it and then he not Tim Kennedy
out something exactly like that where
I'm like I was like I'll freak out and
I'd be like I don't know they both have
a [ __ ] dub in there I don't know yeah
and then something very controversial
huh I think it was that one it's not no
that's crazy [ __ ] crazy she's got a
gift it's a gift you got to get I can
read dubs you can read dubs and it's
only that one thing that only want that
one Taylor takes cream which lasts maybe
like seven seconds I don't know I've
tried to do it from the other hook and
other ones don't work it like cuz really
forced way off and I'm like wait whoa
whoa nobody has a dub anywhere like it's
no dub to be found
Oh
and so crazy sometimes it's not right
though but for the most part it is
beyond probability it's beyond chance
it's yeah it's like ridiculous and it's
not by the odds whatsoever it's just
totally old up in the eye it's crazy
well someday we'll have to like live do
it we should can see my face as the
music goes well we've the only way we
would be able to do that as if we could
like live stream it no you just record
it well cuz we could have the whole
fight record if we work well that's true
right okay yeah yeah and then post it
after so you could see a pic yeah yeah
for sure it's pretty silly it's [ __ ]
cool if you care about fights and stuff
like that do you wanna know how I think
it's gonna go down yes okay so Daniel
Cormier a Daniel Cormier is um he
doesn't look good noise is quiet sir uh
he doesn't really look like the typical
athlete but he does have a hell of a
wrestler game like yeah alright can I
hear you jeez you lost your daddy's
shirt privileges get out go um anyway
he's good wrestler like as much as I
think he's not gonna win this fight
which I don't think he's gonna win he's
a good wrestler so I see him taking
Jones down by pushing Rome against cage
and pulling a leg or you know some sort
of trip or maybe a you know a slam some
sort of thing he'll get Jones down maybe
two-three times throughout the whole
fight the fight is not going to go the
distance Jones is going to submit cornea
in the fourth round and it's going to
happen when Jones is being brought up
against the fence because cornea is only
good game plan is to push Jones on his
heels keep him up against the fence and
just beat him up choose that you know
use his head as a you know as pushing
yeah head pressure like wrestlers do and
and just take him down beat him up well
it's boring but it's his best game plan
this is best shot a trained Jones is
going to land a couple of those you know
when the guys going for takedown against
defense and they throw those like side
elbows he's gonna land a couple of those
to which Cormier is going to react
improperly to and Jones is going to lock
up the guillotine and then he's gonna
switch in the round against offense and
he's an efficient like you did mashita
that's what I think's guy
that was a heartbreaking fight and I
want to talk about it anymore
but I think that that's sort of that's a
really good guess I hope yes I hope
that's what happens and I think it's
worth noting it's very feasible yeah and
I think it's worth noting that this is
the only fight ever that I've wanted
Jones to win because I've always looked
forward to watching Jones fight but I've
never rooted for him for some reason
I've never been able to get past his
persona or whatever it is but I think a
combination of the fact that lately he's
just kind of wearing the [ __ ]
personality he's just like going full
force with it I can respect that
and also I really don't care for Daniel
Cormier I would agree this kind of made
himself out to be quite the ass so I'm
really rooting for John Jones this fight
although I can't [ __ ] wait til he
fights Gustafson again that was the most
one of the most incredible fights I've
ever watched ever in my life ever and
contrary to what Twitter said Gustafson
one was insane won that fight are you
[ __ ] kidding me
he will not God anyways I don't want to
talk about that it was a bunch a double
fight it's gonna be bananas UFC 182
what's in Las Vegas it's the only fight
it's it's it's the only play we've
talked about on the podcast and we've
talked about alone to podcast the last
is funny
uh you got cowboy Cerrone fighting miles
jury
Nate Marquardt's fighting uh what is his
name Oh Brad Tavares I love Breton
Tamar's I think Brad Tavares is going to
get a big win this Saturday he's gonna
beat Marquardt but there's not too many
big names on that card Oh clay guida
okay look I said big names and you think
Clay Guida
what leader yeah hey guys it's me clay
guida
just here to take out your trash you got
a big fight this says so my brother and
I when we just watch Clegg we did clay
who does this guy with long crazy hair
he just goes like this the whole thing
he's got incredible cardio but he's not
the greatest fighter no describe how he
looks okay so he looks like he looks
like a cro-magnon with long long hair
and he's like short and stocky and he
fights with all this movement like his
game is to just move and it's just
exhausting he
looks like a weird hippie trash man
that's like roaming Venice Beach
I didn't stalk I've been short and like
it's thick like he's strong and ripped
but he's not thin he's like [ __ ] welcome
Jun this party TV dude peaches turn on
the TV oh my god you want me to go turn
I can volume up are you idea you
describe clay glue yeah turn the volume
on for TV cuz peach just turned it on
not Eve oh my god that [ __ ] [ __ ]
dog alright um clay guida he's short
he's really hairy
he's long hair he's always doing this
head movement trying to distract and
exhaust his opponents and a lot of times
he'll win like that but a lot of times
he'll get knocked out because he's not
the greatest fighter but um so clay my
brother and I used to watch my brother
Marlon and I used to watch fights ever
like religiously we would be huge fight
fans like together and we watched Clay
Guida and Marlon he basically put
together his theory of how Clay Guida
trains and this was he takes his trailer
and he ties a rope to it and he puts the
rope on his back and he just goes like
this across the country and then he
shows up at the fire any fights I got
some other Browns a theory of how things
just and it's not [ __ ] he's just in
crowd he's got cuz he he can move for 25
minutes like it's nothing but that's
about it
so I thought was funny when I said
big-time fight or whatever and he said
no no Clay Guida
anyways I like Clay Guida because he
seems to give no [ __ ] no Fox you look at
his fights he just goes in there any
[ __ ] goes does a cartwheel and give
though folks oh my god clay
hey guys me cuz we don't here for my job
my go get paid at the end of this and
just food again quick can you feel my
trailer up with gas I'll be okay hey
guys it's me clay we know king I just
get peanuts in money and he used to do
like put his kettlebell workouts on
video and he just looks like such a
weird monster when he works out anyways
no disrespect to Clay Guida I love it
that is what you look like that's what
you look like here's a man Clay Guida
so no the answer is no Clay Guida is not
fighting please like what no big me when
they get to that screen and goes huh huh
huh and I'm like oh that person got the
Dove in their eye but I really want like
yeah well it's like when he fought Chad
Mendes like this year and I was like
Jenna there's no way in [ __ ] hell
Chad's gonna lose to Clay Guida and
Jenna's like I don't know I don't know
and then Chad goes they're just [ __ ]
starches him for Glee Glee nut yeah
Chad's killer too um anyway that's our
little MMA portion of the podcast I hope
you guys enjoyed it I'm really excited
for this yeah we're super psyched if you
guys have pics or care about this ficar
why don't you leave in the comments so
we can yeah in our last podcast like I
want to go back and watch that yeah you
know what they're going to before this
Saturday like if John's in theory John
Jones in fearing kill Daniel Cormier
like would it be murder or not God
what if he did it on the stairs on the
way into the cage oh my god is it
premeditated murder what if he did it on
the first stair oh no like that's what
we did the whole pot yes what if he did
it I'll link that for you press
conference afterwards after he lost but
is it premeditated its premeditative he
lost not if he won and then kills him oh
my god um but yeah good stuff looking
I'm pumped up about I'm super psyched
can we get chicken wings Oh chicken
wings in MMA it's the best combo ever it
really is so yeah you guys should try
that it's like I don't really watch a
whole lot of football I know that you
watch football and I used to watch a lot
of football yeah my family days are my
friends did but I mean oh no I don't
want to waste my chicken wings on yeah
you know everybody's just a better combo
Emma Mayen wings it's a better combo
just gonna do it alright Emma Mayen
Wings in Saturday that's what we're
gonna be doing if you guys do that you
rock but leave your comments on the your
fights and also your New Year's
resolutions and your opinions on New
Year's resolutions because I'm
interested to hear what you guys think
yeah do you think I can clean a jerk 150
by the end of the 2015
year do you think that I can dry brush
more fella than like a week I want to
make a vlog of Jenner dry brush shake so
you guys what see you then
I'm ass-naked when I do it no vlogging
me dry brush right maybe Lily giggity
goo in your head either
alright I will make a part of it I'll
just watch with me and if you blur out
I'm not gonna blur I'll just get a vlog
of your legs and also swing around and
go up to your face no I'm not gonna [ __ ]
with your privacy like that come on no
you can video me dry brushing as long as
you blur the [ __ ] out of my body
where's the head in a brush all right
you guys want to see some blurred ass
login that's happy weird anyway
thank you guys for watching the podcast
yeah goop is in listening for disease I
guess for those of you listen on iTunes
I know [ __ ] great great finish to the
year I'm excited about this podcast in
the new year hopefully sometime we could
upgrade our equipment make us look
pretty or other back yeah we're trying
to get a different camera that we can
use for everything yeah religious we
have a video camera that we can use for
the podcast because it records long
enough and then I have my camera for my
videos and stuff that will not record
enough to me we're trying to consolidate
into a new good one movie cuz we
currently have two cameras that do two
different things and you get one camera
that does everything and also just a big
huge thank you to everyone for your
continued support we were one of the
picks for 2014 iTunes podcast absolutely
yeah that's right and thank you so much
for that I don't know if we thank to you
on the actual podcast I know I did on
Twitter it's right we didn't say
anything on here thank you guys so much
for supplying us and watching us and
listening to us like it and it's never
been any less shitty or less
professional it's just [ __ ] turn on
the mic you go which is awesome that you
guys care still yeah so thank you so
much for that we love you guys really
appreciate all of your continued support
because [ __ ] man
like I've been you know on the internet
for a hot minute now and some of you
guys have been with me for like my adult
life that's true
and I know who you are too cuz I stock
you back
anyways anyway you guys are awesome
we'll see you next week in the new year
and we gonna drink some sangria sangria
toes tell you y'all have a safe new year
you know enjoy it but don't regret it
for sure and don't forget that New
Year's Eve is one of the highest nights
for DUI so please don't drink and drive
just get it over I'll pay for it text me
if you live in the middle of [ __ ]
disease dead EMU Bert oh [ __ ] planet
all right please have a designated
driver or just get with a bunch of dogs
and get a dogsled that's true if you're
in the right part of the country yeah
but don't give you these dogs because
then that's also junk okay this is gonna
take some plans okay love you Jason for
have a goodies
music I think Bing
[Music]